-Our next guest is an Emmy-
and Golden Globe-nominated
writer, director, and actress.
You know her from her work on
"Killing Eve" and "The Crown."
Her feature-film directorial
debut, "Promising Young Woman,"
which she also wrote
and produced,
has earned her three
Academy Award nominations
for Best Picture, Best Director,
and Best Original Screenplay.
Let's take a look.
-May I ask what prompted
your desire
to get back to your studies?
-I guess...I couldn't stop
thinking about my time here.
-Yeah,
it's an extraordinary place.
It's an unusual request.
-Yes, but I left under
unusual circumstances.
-Oh.
-I left because
of what happened to Nina.
-Mm.
-Nina Fisher?
You don't remember her?
Maybe you remember
Alexander Monroe?
-Oh, yes!
Alexander Monroe.
He actually just came back
and gave a talk here.
Oh, he's a --
he's a really nice guy.
Really smart.
Are you a friend of his?
-No.
-Please welcome to the show
Emerald Fennell.
How are you, Emerald?
-I'm good, thank you.
I'm great.
-Congratulations, obviously,
on all the nominations.
I'm always curious to find out
where were you
and how did you get the news?
-Well, I was at home in England,
and I made
a really terrible error,
which was that
daylight savings time,
which, at the best of times,
is the worst thing ever,
it happened in America
but not in England.
And so I was on a Zoom call when
I got a text from Josh O'Connor,
who plays Prince Charles
in "The Crown,"
saying,
"Congratulations! Oscars!"
I said, "What?"
And he's like,
"Why am I telling you this?
You need to be watching this."
And so then, my husband came in,
and he had the live feed,
and, you know, I just --
I think I blacked out.
I think there was
a lot of screaming.
Like, a lot of screaming.
And it's like, I don't know.
Nobody expects this thing.
Especially when you make
an independent film.
You know, so, like, it's just
the most incredible thing ever.
-It's an independent film.
It's also an incredibly
unique film.
When did this idea first occur
to you as a screenplay?
-Well, I think, you know,
I've just been thinking a lot
about growing up
and the kinds of things
that were jokes
in movies and in TV shows.
You know,
the concept of girls waking up
with bodies next to them,
not knowing who they were.
And, you know, guys spying
on women in their locker rooms
and getting people drunk
or waiting for the drunk girl
at the end of the party.
You know,
it was just, like, banter.
It was just stuff
that was just completely normal.
And that was, you know,
regrettably,
part of all of our lives.
And so, I think I've just been
thinking about that a lot,
the kind of very disturbingly
commonplace stuff about consent.
And, yeah, you know, the thing
that came into my head
was a very, very drunk girl
lying on a bed
being undressed by a guy,
you know, drunkenly saying,
"What are you doing,
what are you doing?"
And then suddenly sitting up and
saying, "What are you doing?"
And that "What are you doing?"
felt like the beginning
of the movie.
-There -- This is a movie where
it's very important
not to give anything away,
but I had read before I saw it
that this is one of the last
movies where there were
actual screenings where people
saw it in a theater together
and that an actual fight broke
out because there is a moment
that people could see
very different ways
or have very different
reactions to.
Were you in the theater
when that happened,
or did you hear about it?
-No, I was in the theater.
And it was my first
test screening.
It was my only test screening
I've ever attended.
And I sort of said to the
producers and the distributors
who were all there,
"I'll go and sit at the back.
I just want to really
hear everyone," you know?
"I really want to -- want to
really experience everything."
And then, of course, I sat down,
and the guy next to me went,
"What is this?"
-[ Laughs ]
And the woman right next to him
went, "I don't know."
It's like, "Oh, no. Oh, no.
Why I am I sitting here?"
And so I was very far away,
but what happened,
there's a scene in the film,
which is, you know,
very disturbing.
And somebody in the audience
liked it,
and the other person did not.
And there was a lot of shouting.
And my only thought was,
"Oh, great. Okay.
Well, this movie
is never gonna be released."
-And yet --
And yet here you are.
I also want to mention briefly
or mostly just a compliment
your work on "The Crown."
Here you are
as Camilla Parker Bowles.
Some of the best
"smoking in bathtub" acting
we've seen
certainly in this century.
Did you enjoy doing it?
-Thank you so much.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes, that was one of the --
that was a very, very difficult
performance for me.
A real stretch.
Look, actually, joking aside,
it was very hard,
because the bath was very hot.
And I had to smoke
30,000 cigarettes,
and actually, by the end,
I remember
I sort of slid out of the bath
like a sort of beached whale.
And everyone in the room,
you know,
usually people are discreetly
looking away politely,
but in this case,
they were sort of recoiling.
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't great
for the self-confidence.
But, you know,
they were quite right to do so.
-Well, hopefully,
there's plenty now
for you to have nothing
but confidence about.
Best of luck
at the Academy Awards.
And thank you so much
for making time for us today.
-Of course.
Thank you so much.
-"Promising Young Woman"
is in theaters and on demand
and available to own
on digital and DVD.